are you trying to grow your youtube
channel this year do you want to get
more views and subscribers well it's
shows like this that can help you move
your channel forward because you can get
a behind-the-scenes look at channel
reviews and you can ask your questions
live during today's show my name is
heather torres and you're watching the
youtube made simple show let's get into
it
[Music]
welcome to the youtube made simple show
i am your host of the this show author
of the book youtube made simple coming
out later this year and i am so excited
to do today's episode because i get to
do channel reviews and not just channel
reviews by myself i have a lovely
co-host and guest today which is rob
from vid iq hey rob how you doing hey
thank you heather thank you for
introducing me as a lovely co-host that
is uh very much appreciated
my radiant
host
that i like this i'm gonna just keep
coming up with really good names for you
rob i was gonna say youtube sensation
also because rob's joining us from the
vid iq channel which has now surpassed a
million subscribers helping content
creators every single day and rob is
actually one of their core creators or
one of their lead creators on the
channel and he's actually joining us
today to be going through uh different
channel reviews because today's episode
is brought to you by vid iq and rob you
guys have some fascinating things
happening over at vid iq to help content
creators move forward why don't you tell
us about one of the new features that
will be coming out soon yeah so as you
may or may not know vid iq
is a software that you can add to your
desktop extension or mobile and it kind
of adds
more options to making better data
data-driven decisions and we have tools
such as channel audit daily ideas
uh views per hour velocity but the one i
wanted to quickly show you today is
something that we're getting really
excited about as it's the title
generator
and what this basically allows you to do
is take one of the ideas we may suggest
to you and turn it into a really
intriguing clickable title for example i
will quickly demonstrate on this video
that we have here i'm just going to
change this title quickly to youtube
mistakes
and that might be your idea but it's not
necessarily a good title
we have this button here which says get
ai title recommendations you click that
and within a few seconds you have five
different title ideas youtube mistakes
every newbie should know doesn't that
add
a bit more target audience definition
and an emotional attachment to that idea
of youtube mistakes or maybe you're
gonna make some really embarrassing
youtube mistakes like a 30 second video
intro which nobody wants to watch if you
didn't like any of these ideas you
simply click refresh and it will give
you another five ideas
now the reason i'm showing you this
particular video is because we used our
tool
on this video and this is the suggestion
almost verbatim that came from this
generator five mistakes that send your
channel to youtube hell from the idea
youtube mistakes and that turned out to
be a 1 of 10 video so that's all the
validation we need for this tool it is
fantastic we're going to be
branching out to more parts of our tool
this is kind of like a teaser look but
it has been rolled out to all users so
free to use i think you get like five
suggestions per month so
anybody can just try this out to see how
powerful it could be for your channel
oh my goodness rob this makes me so
excited because i think coming up with
title ideas is like one of the hardest
parts about youtube you want it to be
clickable and so
you so vidiq is using the ai and all the
computer magic to figure out the right
titles for us that's such a cool idea
yeah definitely titles that are
clickable for humans i think that's a
real challenge i still struggle with
that so now whenever i'm writing a title
i always just put the the title within
this idea generator just to see if it
will give me different angles of
approach and then i have a few to fall
back on if the video is not performing
as well as i assume it would do
so so good and i like to take other
titles and i will write those down in my
journal also if it's not like title
number one i think i'll make that same
video in three months with a different
angle because that's also a good title
so what a great tool to be able to
generate those titles um you can go
ahead and try a free trial 30 days we
are partnered with
vid iq for this you can go to
vidiq.comthink
and that is how you can get your 30 day
free trial i love it iq i was actually
just training someone yesterday rob on
vid iq and her mind was blown she was
like all of this is available i'm like
yes all of this is available to you yeah
uh for new creators experience creators
it's such a um phenomenal tool to have
well rob we're going to jump into the
first segment today which is doing some
channel reviews we already have had all
of our channels submitted and questions
along with them we're actually um
highlighting some of our video ranking
academy students in this channel review
segment so rob why don't you kick it off
with your first channel review and then
all bounce back on after that sure yeah
i will apologize in advance for any
names i mispronounced that is a trait of
me when i'm doing uh channel audits but
we'll start with amanda
ensley their channel is easy acres
shipping container home
and their question regarding their
channel if you want to share my screen
which i think i now have up i'm
struggling as a vlog type channel my
content was recorded months ago when we
first started building our home i've
tried to add some current videos too i
could use some advice on making my
videos more appealing and viewer
friendly so i think from that point of
view
i would say that the messaging of a
channel perhaps needs to be a little
more accessible for example easy acres
shipping container home
i don't know if that really has like the
family friendly vibe to it as well as a
channel banner which is a little
non-descripts
and when you look at the videos
themselves as well if you look at the
thumbnails and indeed the titles i think
these are all generally very functional
they're not appealing to a particular
viewers motivations goals fears or
excitement
and so every time i look at one of these
thumbnails it's taking me i would say 10
to 15 seconds to decode what the video
is about so i would be investing time
since you say you've already made a lot
of this content investing time into
thumbnails that have more of an
emotional draw to them and a viewer
can instantly
take recognition from where they're
scrolling through the feed like you need
a thumbnail you need a scroll stopper in
terms of your thumbnails and these for
me right now
just don't do that so
i think in summary you say that you're
trying to work out how to appeal more to
a viewer
there's a lot of things in the
channel presentation and the thumbnails
and titles that could be more viewer
friendly
yeah and i would say too rob consistency
in the text on thumbnails is something
that i've been talking to people a lot
about because even just the
inconsistency of the font or the color
um not every video matters but also just
looking at it saying i'm not seeing a
brand consistency here really happening
as well and i was doing a study on my
own self rob because that's one of the
ways i like to study youtube and one of
the things i did was i would watch a
video and i wouldn't subscribe and then
i would look at my home screen to see do
i see a video from the same person
popping up on my home screen and the way
i could identify that was one topic but
two the brand awareness of that actual
channel so really great advice um for
uh her and um thank you for that review
rob
no problem yeah
a really good point you made about um
what the viewer sees next uh youtube
said recently if a hundred people watch
one of your videos this week
700 people will see
a title and a thumbnail from your video
next week so as you say that
instant connection brand awareness even
if it's not necessarily through logos it
can be done through consistent fonts
style of picture and colors within the
thumbnail
so so good rob i'm going to have you do
the next one real quick while i take
another drink of water because my throat
all of a sudden is sure i need to give
out so head on over to your next one rob
all right then blake rice and their
channel name is time for tech and the
question they ask us
is what makes a good compelling title
and thumbnail i feel like that's
something i'm struggling with pulling
people into my videos so i'm just going
to take a brief overview of your channel
and where you are
you're approaching 400 subscribers which
is pretty solid and i can see that
you're posting content on a
fairly regular basis and you know just
on first impressions as i look at you
and where you are on your youtube
journey i would actually say that your
thumbnails are actually pretty striking
you're going to the
um limit extent sometimes of actually
dressing up in costume to um
create your thumbnails which i think is
fantastic so you're really getting that
emotional
uh pull in terms of stopping the swipe
in terms of the titles themselves again
i think they are very thought-provoking
these fake airpods fooled apple you know
that's the type of title i think our ai
title generator uh would create so
i would say in general i don't think
you're doing anything particularly wrong
with the thumbnails and the titles what
it might be is topic consistency for
example you're talking about
um some new uh airpods google airpods
and then you're talking about android
and samsung then apple and then you're
talking about transferring data from a
clunky pc to a mighty macbook so you're
going through tutorials opinion pieces
many different pieces of tech
it could be that you're just trying to
cover too broader angle of technology at
this point where your channel size is
i'm going to sort by most popular this
is the kind of the cheat that we always
go to is channel auditors but is there
anything that's really jumping out here
that um
you are a master of and again i don't
really see it i'm seeing something about
google play i'm seeing some video the
google cloud doing some macbook air
stuff i feel as if you if you focus on
one particular avenue of a company a
brand or a piece of technology for five
to ten videos and track the audience and
whether they're growing on that
particular topic uh just to see how that
might work for your channel
so i think that concludes my review this
one are you back yay there we are thank
you i am back thanks rob um and yeah
that that's such a key point of just
like
keep it brand consistent keep your
topics consistent and that can help
people um all right i'm gonna bring up
over newbin over newben is the next one
up for us today and um if you uh would
like let me get my there we go uh over
newbin as question was i'm just starting
understanding how youtube is working and
once the videos that you've currently
created to start working for you uh you
want to make some adjustments moving
forward but curious what should those
adjustments be in order to move forward
and when i look at this channel i am
seeing um this channel is producing uh
quite a bit of content when i look i've
got eight videos in the last month uh
this is vid iq plugin tool showing me
the stats you are up by 17 subscribers
and your views are at 1500
views now if you want to go back and
optimize your channel i recommend that
you go to your top 10 list you have
enough data here on your channel to show
what your top 10 producing videos are so
i would go back and i would say what are
my top 10 producing videos how can i
optimize them even more here's some ways
i would optimize them one
i would optimize the thumbnails the
thumbnail looking great is there
consistency in the brand is there some
way that i could make this thumbnail
more clickable um number two is the
title so is the title uh exactly what
you want someone to see for them to
click on it so if i'm looking at this
current title
i'm seeing lj noob nug
s1 e1 naming your jeep
i would work on the titles of your
videos but i wouldn't go back and change
all of them i would just look at the top
ten and if you have access to vid iq
tool you can definitely use that to help
you generate that title
and then i would start to look at your
next batch of videos well we want to go
back and we want to optimize we want to
do everything we can for what we've
already created the future is forward my
friend and so i want you to be thinking
about what is the next batch of videos
that you're going to be creating on your
channel looks like you've been doing
this now for about two years but really
getting serious i can tell up in this
segment
and um
just thinking about who you're reaching
and how you're reaching them is going to
be key to knowing what videos you should
be working on next so that would be my
advice to you for getting started um on
youtube as you are moving forward with
really realizing what is working well
for your channel all right next up we've
got uh the blended and blessed family
and your question that you posed was um
i would love to get your thoughts on my
recent change and focus on my channel
i've worked hard on thumbnails and
titles and i think the quality of my
content is getting much better so if i
were to look at this the blended and
blessed family
i'm looking here and i'm seeing that
you're doing like best of this resort
that's
i mean you can already tell that that is
a searched uh based content at 1.4k
subscribers in four days when your video
before that of eating healthy on
vacation was only 49 views so i already
think that the direction you're going of
search based content
is a really really smart idea and i can
see here that you were kind of figuring
out what you wanted to do and then you
really started up here
dialing in a little bit more but i can
see that you're still in the discovery
phase of your channel um when i looked
at your channel i was like okay what am
i actually seeing i'm seeing weight loss
journey i'm seeing blended family i'm
seeing uh midlife crisis and so really
trying to identify who you're helping
with this channel and how you're helping
them is going to be a key now when i
read just the name of your channel the
blended and blessed family
i'm actually feeling like i'm going to
be getting family
content just even though it's my blended
and blessed family i would assume that
it's family content so eating healthy on
vacation
doesn't feel aligned with the name of
the channel or the when i see that what
i would assume the direction of the
channel would be so i feel like there is
a values alignment
misalignment happening
um
because it's not helping me understand
how
how staying healthy on vacation and how
to overcome the loss of a loved one are
combined for the same person so i would
just really be working on a little bit
more dive into i know you're part of
video ranking academy so i would
encourage you to dive in even more into
the module
about finding your niche going through
your niche finder because that's going
to help you really identify those two
big keys pieces who are you for and how
are you helping them and then what's the
messaging and the topics that you're
discussing when it comes to that channel
all right rob who do you have up next
next channel is monique sharp simpson
their channel is called i'm going to
turn the one into an i skids learning
channel and their question is i focus on
kids material i animate informational
videos about animals and i do original
stories bedtime stories etc my channel
had good momentum in the middle of last
year and it abruptly fell off with all
the restrictions around kids channels
should i abandon ship or just try harder
so i would love your input on this one
heather after i've had a look through
the channel because um
i i have relatively little knowledge and
experience of kids channel specifically
but what i will say from a broader
perspective is that
um the obvious thing to say is you you
haven't been posting much content in the
last six months uh everything on the top
row here is from the last five months
and when i look at the stats these are
for the last six months the view counts
seem fairly consistent
so
since the
i guess supposed drop-off of your
channel things are have leveled out
and
another thing to consider is that
i would say your thumbnails within the
[Music]
space
are
solid maybe a five or six out of ten but
in terms of how you could use the fonts
a little better and have them a bit more
i'd say thicker and bubbly and more um
appealing to a a child audience there
could be something there and also maybe
just the objects
lack a little bit of um
color and richness to them a real punch
compared to other channels likely in
your space and then what i i would also
think about here is
to almost test the waters and see where
your channel stands in the kids content
space it's look at your most popular
videos and say
i can even remake this video by abc baby
animals because you likely have a brand
new audience to appeal to or you use
that as a theme for several series of
videos it might be abc
fish or abc farm animals or abc
family members
go
using the same title
and video formats to look at this
particular titling structure that's
worked in the past
because i don't think there's anything
necessarily ever wrong about redoing
content which is a little bit older
because no doubt you've learned more
about the craft and you can make a
better version of the previous video but
yeah heather if you had any thoughts
just generally about kids content i'd
love to hear them
yeah and um i would also say rob this
also is probably my uh least this and
gaming are probably my least um it's
music and kids for me but yeah
you know
we can we can give um our advice by the
way this is our personal advice based on
the knowledge we have about youtube no
one has deemed us youtube professionals
in that way so this is our advice rob
you really gave some some key points
there just even about um really thinking
about kids content is still thinking
about the audience that's going to click
on it so what i would really be looking
at like rob said the idea of you know
how how enticing is your content to want
to click on i think the thing about kids
content that is different than other
content is the way that you can actually
monetize kids content and the
interaction that you can have you're
building a different type of community
which you just have to know that if that
is the space you're choosing to go into
that is always my key with gaming and
with kids content is you're choosing to
go down that route and so it's just like
if you were to choose to open a coffee
shop versus a
hamburger shop you're choosing the
avenue that you want to make your money
on youtube or your revenue or build your
business on youtube so within that you
have to understand the constraints that
are part of that and so when it comes to
kids content specifically while we can
give you the best advice for clickable
thumbnails and titles a lot of it has to
do with the suggestions that are brought
up because it's not like kids are going
to the search bar and typing certain
things in now maybe parents go and they
type in you know um
i know i do this for my kids like we
were learning the usa we were learning
like the uh a song about all of the
states in the usa i typed in
songs for united states i typed that in
and then i was like have free rings kids
choose any of these ones on here and
they chose it based off of looking back
off of how cool the thumbnail was
because they weren't interested in the
best clickable title they wanted the
coolest thumbnail so when you're
thinking about kids content specifically
or gaming content specifically
the click the the audience that you're
serving still matters and kids content
gets
millions and millions of views so it's
not that it's not content that is good
to create it's just understanding the
game you're playing and you're choosing
to play a sub game in a game because of
choosing kids content so i hope that
helps and gives you some clarity i think
that kids channels can really win
but you have to understand what game
you're playing and if you're just
creating content just to create content
that's just a really great hobby and if
you're choosing to make it a business
you have to understand what are the
pieces that could make it a successful
business is it brand deals is it adsense
it you know what are you what avenues
are you choosing to do when you choose
to go down the road of kids content so
i'm in music i guess rob would be
another one of those because there's
certain games you can play in music you
can't do copyrighted music and get paid
um on those pieces so
i hope that i hope that helps um and
then also um there is a separate piece
of youtube for kids content which is the
only
separated piece of youtube right there's
youtube kids which is its own
ecosystem
outside of just the big ecosystem of
youtube so i would
really recommend that if you're choosing
to go down the route of kids content
that you're spending 10 20 30 hours
studying what works for kids content
that's a big deal rob and i give you the
all the advice in the world but if
you're studying what's working if you're
reading the articles if you're
understanding the laws if you're
understanding the pieces of youtube
that's going to give you a bigger edge
overall on the content that you're
creating
wow
wow rob wow
[Laughter]
um
i could go on and on about about these
uh these sections but let's jump into
the next uh the next review rob this
comes from jamie and maybe you can help
me with this because i'm not really
familiar with card fights um are you
familiar with card fights rob this is
such a unique and interesting category
um they've been on youtube for a little
while doing youtube and really just want
to know what recommendation is for the
next level for their channel i'll give
some brief thoughts that i have right
away and then maybe you can jump on if
you have some card fighting advice uh
for this but what i'm seeing is that
this type of channel um you are reaching
an audience that is into
these particular um it says insightful
deck profile so i'm assuming that these
are these are specific games right and
this is the same in gaming as it is with
uh content wrapped around certain types
of games uh one is that you know the
popularity of the game matters so i mean
the reason that fortnite is incredible
on youtube is because the popularity of
it is huge the reason that minecraft is
still winning is because the popularity
of it is huge so you need to first take
into account what is the market that
you're trying to reach how big is it so
when i'm looking and i'm seeing that um
you posted
four years ago and got six thousand
views and i'm getting your newest videos
at 174
436. i'm just looking at like what is
the popularity of the exact
um i would say games or decks that
you're choosing in comparison to others
because the part of youtube that matters
is the idea of being in the right space
at the right time so choosing the right
game is going to be very important i
would also say that
your thumbnails are extremely busy and
it's really really difficult for me to
even read
what the actual um game is like this one
says
next lvl gaming playmate giveaway thank
you one point k subs
i had to like zoom in to see that so i
would really be working on just the
click ability of your thumbnails and
then i would really go after the
keywords of the exact games that you're
trying to reach so you can go into vid
iq and do some keyword research they'll
give you some video ideas as well
there's a video ideas generator in there
and inside vid iq they can help you
learn
what content is actually being searched
on this topic so that's the advice i
would have and i would say you know
youtube also is just it's about
it's about testing it's always about
testing and it's always about finding
what's working right now rob any advice
for
games like this
yeah can you just bring up a channel
again um because what i was trying to
establish here was what actual game it
was
because i couldn't see a consistent
um game title
in the videos and i think it's vanguard
card fight
i think is the game
and
what i'm seeing here is a nice level of
consistency in terms of views per video
which tend to be very similar so you
know that the i think that likely means
that you have a good return audience
but you don't necessarily have a new
audience finding your content
why is that well as ever kind of alluded
to it could depend on the um the total
size of the audience and it may be
you've already gathered a considerable
size of our audience and there's just
not that many people interested in this
topic but that means you're one of the
leaders in this space you have a
dominant position here i think as you
kind of hit it here as well um heather
the thumbnails may be a little
impenetrable or accessible to new
viewers and usually in the card space
whether it be fifa ultimate team or
pokemon card collecting
focus on a particular
card
from the game and sell the um
the benefits of this card or like it's
amazingly rare or you get unbelievable
experience points or intelligence points
or whatever points they are on this on
this card you know sell the value of a
particular card uh in the thumbnail and
while that's going to be important for
you to click on that thumbnail to find
out more about it oh we've seen it all
right so he he wears a sailor's cap by
playing a bit of a character there
that's pretty cool
um
so yeah i think um
the content is accessible probably for a
hardcore audience but for a more casual
audience perhaps
working on a thumbnails little bit may
help you and this is where you can do a
search on youtube and see what the um
the biggest creators in your space and
how they're designing their thumbnails
and how you can maybe
borrow some cues from them but then make
it your thumbnail and your voice within
the marketing of that thumbnail
yeah and i think going back to even just
searched base type content i mean i
don't even know what vancard vanguard
card games is but if i just put that
into the search box uh in youtube
youtube's already giving me ideas so
have you made this video vanguard card
game for beginners maybe there's four
steps or i want to learn how to play it
what's different between that and a
battle i have no idea you can make those
videos and so these become videos that
people are searching for
in
youtube's ecosystem so when they're
excited about vanguard card game
um they're coming to youtube and they're
wanting to learn how to play what's the
best way to do this uh i had i had
someone i was coaching who did a chess
channel and they were you know and i
said go back to like just type in like
how to play chess and then space and
make every single one of those videos
and you'll start to see an audience grow
that's passionate about chess and so the
same thing could happen for you over
here um with the helping people with a
specific
skill or answering their specific
question to help them
learn how to play the game where you
then become more of an authority in this
game space so that's just another
option as well all right rob uh let's
get to a few more of our channel reviews
and we'll start doing some q a in the
next segment yeah the next channel is
kinzoba regina
i hope i've pronounced your name
correctly and your question is
new channel here but it seems that my
dance demos and talking head videos are
not performing as well as my tutorials
i think i did an alright job with the
editing etc even though i'm a beginner
am i missing something here
and my answer to that is
the only thing you're missing here which
is something that you will gain over
time is experience of the the youtube
recommendation system and how it treats
different pieces of content
this is a wild generalization but a lot
of small creators usually get noticed
through
search
tutorials solution based content so
that's probably why the video here has
nearly 2 000 views start dancing uh
today and the dance tutorial whereas
these videos don't quite have as many
views because they're more
opinion based and
right now
where you are on your youtube journey
and this is not a fault of your own or a
problem that is exclusive to your
yourself
right now because people don't
necessarily know who you are they don't
might possibly care about your opinions
on a particular topic but that will
change as people watch more of your
content and they get to know you more
then they start to invest more in you as
a creator and not just the value you're
providing in your content
so that might be why there's a
discrepancy between view counts but
what i would say is for a channel that's
only been on youtube for a couple of
months and i have seven videos to have a
video that's already close to a couple
of thousands of views and most videos
getting more than 100 views i think
you're already in a very good place it's
just gonna require i would say at this
point a bit of volume testing your
different topics really good thumbnails
as well to start with uh um kenzobo i'm
really impressed by them
yeah and i you're so right rob i think
sometimes it's it's too early to tell
right we got all this time to experiment
and to figure out you know what content
we really like to do i noticed rob when
you were growing uh um when you were
growing the vid iq channel did you have
that time also of kind of just
experimenting to figure out what type of
videos to make still experimenting now
to be honest ever
um i think it was a little different
with vidiq because um
i had like my first objective was to do
all of the tutorials for
the tools at vid iq but then when i
started to think about the educational
aspect it became less about just talking
about vidiq products and more about the
i'm a creator just the same as all of
you creators who are watching my content
so let's try and grow together so
there's kind of that evolution
of an appreciation of
the target audience why are they
watching my content and it's
the first hand it's not necessarily so
that vidiq can try and sell them a
product it's a i want to get to a
thousand subscribers by monetizing my
channel well first of all i need to
educate you on the fact that if you have
that mindset then it's going to be very
hard to get there because you want to
think about your audience first and the
value that you're going to provide to
them and then somewhere along in the
video i might just talk about a
particular vidiq product that you can
use to help you know like the title
generator so yeah it was kind of an
evolution of understanding the audience
a little bit more yeah and that took
hundreds of videos to to get anywhere
close to getting right
so so good yeah i feel like the same
thing is always happening here i'm
always experimenting always trying to
figure out what the next
best video is but it's really honing in
so much on who you're helping and how
you help them and really figuring out
that audience because once you can build
an audience of thriving fans that's when
you can really start to talk about other
things if you'd like to
on your channel so all right let's bring
up the next one is the keeling farms and
keeling farms uh looks like you're just
getting started on youtube which is
really exciting um you're posting a lot
of content also when i was looking over
here
at the uh stats of youtube eight videos
this month alone
which is so good you've grown by 54
subscribers and 3
600 views congrats on that such a great
accompli accomplishment to have and your
question was um you feel like you are
growing slow in the farming niche i want
to educate people about what we do on
the farm and share our journey but you
can't tell if you're picking the right
niche and bouncing between specific
topics like sheep cattle pigs or family
farming now
you are in a great niche and you're
actually in a growing niche farming has
taken on a whole new um uh um
people are more interested now in
farming and in uh sustainable living um
that is a growing trend just in the
world alone so you are already
positioning yourself in a really great
place and bouncing if you're thinking
the difference between like sheep and
and and um what you said sheep and cows
you can tell i live in the city okay
sheep cows pigs and family farming um
you are that is farming and so what i
want to share before i go into your
actual channel review is this idea that
first you want to pick who you're
helping
who are you helping are you doing
entertainment style are you helping
other people that are starting farms are
you talking to experienced farmers like
who are you helping have you identified
who that person is and then you want to
go deeper and say okay
so what niche am i in you're in the
farming niche you're clearly in the
farming niche so you've picked your
niece niche now you can think about the
five
to seven buckets of topics that you want
to talk about so it's not necessarily
quote unquote bouncing around if one
video is about sheep and the next video
is about family farming and the next
video is about cattle because those are
just different topics
underneath each one underneath the the
niche and then underneath the bucket of
the topics you would go even deeper into
the titles and the video ideas that
would be interesting to your audience
now i don't know how much research you
have done on your competition but i know
that there are farming channels um that
are in the millions of subscribers and i
would study what they're doing well so
um problem with problem while caffeine
is this a twin part one when i look at
just this first video title
a lot of um vlog channels will fall into
this as well that is not that's not
necessarily search based so the 50
people that are watching are probably
part of your audience that is returning
right because this is not something that
is um that people are searching for
maybe uh
changing that title could really help
people to understand the story that
you're trying to tell when it comes to
if your cow is birthing twins now not
everything you do has to be educational
however you are in a very great
positioned educational channel for new
people coming to the farming space or
interested in farming so i would
actually be looking at the uh the
titles of the videos that you're doing
so that you can make it more search
based and i would make your content
maybe what's called the 80 20 rule 80 of
your content is really search based
content it's talking about um how to
prepare your calf for birth uh
birthing twins uh birthing
calf twins is there a name for that i'm
not really sure maybe there is uh
birthing twin calves or something like
that and then maybe you do the storyline
of it and you're actually talking about
the day or the the birth story of the
calves or something like that but when
it says like morning sheep chores
uploading schedule update you don't
actually have to tell me your uploading
schedule is being updated you as a
content creator can change that at any
time
and the thumbnail of let let's talk that
doesn't help me understand what i'm
clicking on so
i understand that you're probably
telling me a story in vlog style around
your schedule upload but as a viewer
maybe i actually want to know when i see
morning sheep chores i actually think
i'm going to learn about how to do
morning cheap sheep chores so i would
really be thinking about your content in
the in a different way in just a
different context of
search based content and value-based
content for your current level of
subscribers this is a huge niche and
when i even go to what is your most
popular videos
right here
uh bringing home our new pcc south pole
bowl i'll bet south pole bull
is a
is a keyword that people are searching
for and you know how i know that is
because your three top videos are about
this bowl
your three top videos are about south
pole bowl um let's say that three times
fast rob uh that that is where i'm
seeing and even when you just look at
your top ranked videos
are very searchable um cow farming
winter supplements there you go you're
really starting to see um getting our
our hair sheep our missouri trip so this
is you're even seeing what is popular on
your channel and success leaves clues
when it comes to youtube so you want to
be thinking more and more about how can
i help people what niche am i in and
what topics can i discuss underneath
that
heavy can you just bring up that channel
uh i just and go to um
newest again um because
you raise a really good point about um
what does a viewer care about for
example this morning sheep chores as a
viewer
you're right i don't care what you
upload schedule you're changing to
youtube what i want to know as a viewer
is how much
do i have to shovel in the morning when
it comes to sheep and i think that's you
know what that's what may you call it a
little bit of click bait but that's
going to be what's enticing to the
viewer in that type of video so think
about what the the questions
and the motivations of the viewer as
opposed to what you want to tell the
viewer uh about your youtube upload
shadows because anything usually about
community
uh and youtube um
um the mundane youtube stuff you know
that's youtube chores not sheep chores
yeah let's let's move on before uh i'll
overtone even more uh joe go asks uh for
their motorcycle channel uh here how are
my thumbnails and channel arts
and are my views good compared to how
many subscribers i that i have
we'll start with the thumbnails first
and i would say
they are generally good
what i like here for two reasons are
first of all the general consistency
through your thumbnails
and the color scheme which i think is
quite striking and probably
differentiates yourself a little bit
from your potential competition
there are a couple of weird instances
whereby
this one for example is quite a contrast
of a thumbnail so
because you're changing the font quite a
lot people may not realize that it's a
video from you when you publish this and
it appears on the home feed
however i think this thumbnail is really
effective because this is kind of the
uh scroll stopper where you just have an
arrow pointing to somebody who looks a
bit goofy and it's like don't be this
guy and so you're intrigued by the
thumbnail and then the title
motorcycle etiquette i think that's a
really good combination of thumbnail and
title there which would probably get me
to click or in this particular instance
they are still a little bit chaotic the
thumbnails especially when you're using
different fonts and text
and compared to the channel banner which
is a different color scheme and looks as
if you probably made that six months ago
i think the channel banner probably
needs a little bit of updating as well
because the text kind of blends in to
the backgrounds as regards to views
versus subscribers the short answer is
yes i think you have a healthy community
here you're getting hundreds of views
sometimes more views and subscribers
which is always an excellent thing that
means that youtube is reaching well
beyond your current audience to try and
find new audiences for your content and
but what i would say is don't worry too
much about that number especially with
subscriber count i'd say as long as your
baseline level of views per video is
continuing to rise on average over a
long period of time then you're going in
the right track but
generally speaking more views and
subscribers is a big win
that is true rob more views more
subscribers that is the win oh my
goodness well thank you so much
rob for that segment of doing our
channel reviews rob and i we come here
what is it once a month now rob and
we're doing channel reviews here you
also do channel reviews over on vidiq so
that's a great way um if you would like
to uh be a part of getting your channel
reviewed here on this show or over on
the live stream that happens over on vid
iq and we're going to head into a q a
segment and uh just let you know that
this part of today's live is brought to
you by our free youtube masterclass have
you already taken the free
master class uh this is a free on-demand
class that you can take
all you need to do is go to
tubemasterclass.com and when you go over
there you'll actually be taken to a free
on-demand class where you can learn the
secrets to growing to your first 1000
subscribers and earning your first 1 000
and beyond on youtube without fancy
camera any editing experience or working
50 hours a week plus on your youtube
channel i break that down inside of this
free on-demand class that you can get to
if you go to
[Music]
tubemasterclass.com and i am so excited
we've had so many people um joining in
to the master class and then becoming
members of our video ranking academy and
actually today's uh um channel reviews
were were part of our video ranking
academy we do channel reviews inside of
that academy every single month so you
can uh join us there if you would like
to as well all right rob we're gonna do
some of our oh clicking all the buttons
we're gonna do our starred con comments
here dr omar for you rob i have a
medical channel in neurology and i
pivoted from general neurology and uh
and covant team and now focus only on
epilepsy how do i make intriguing titles
and thumbnails
oh this is an interesting one because
you have to tread the very fine line of
credibility and trust
versus
uh an intriguing
almost like you know this stop stop the
swipe in terms of i don't want to say
clickbaity but you know people have to
make that click-worthy title and
thumbnail and that is something that
you're going to um
really uh have a challenge with uh i'm
going to say generally that thank you
ever for bringing up the
channel there i think in terms of the
title instruction that you currently
have which is
including the question in the title i
think is a brilliant approach because
that's exactly what people are going to
be searching for on youtube and i assume
that's going to be where you're getting
uh most of your views so i think the
thumbnails is probably what you want to
be um looking at next in terms of a bit
more consistency in them i've seen you
doing some shorts as well which
obviously don't necessarily need
thumbnails um but
i would say trying to communicate uh
epilepsy
with
more imagery in your thumbnails
uh might be an approach perhaps use it
including epilepsy as one
piece of text maybe in each thumbnail uh
might be an idea as well
thank you rob for that one and dr omar i
know you've been working on this um and
you know a lot of times too when you're
pivoting your content one you have 22
000 subscribers so you're doing things
right uh want to definitely mention that
part of it now you're just pivoting into
being more niche down um i would rob
what are some tools inside of vid iq
that he could use to um really help him
develop out this content strategy what
are some pieces of vid iq because
there's so many pieces that he could be
using to really figure out um how to be
using epilepsy as that key word for what
he's doing okay so just bear with me one
second in the background i'm just going
to try to get this screen up because
there's a there's another tool that
we're
we're just
launching really which may be really
helpful for you i just want to check
that it is working
uh and then i can bring it up let's see
i don't think we've i don't think we've
released it yet which is a real shame
but it's coming soon um we we're
launching a tool
whereby let me just try it let me just
type in let's just let's get behind the
scenes rob let's get let's get a little
taste
i'm trying my best i'm crying it would
help me if i could spell epilepsy right
that's
my dyslexia really not helping me here
happy let's see
i'll get that folks okay
so rob's going to be pulling up a tool
right now so many ways that invid iq you
can really be helped with figuring this
out not just the youtube search bar but
all of what youtube all of what vid iq
can really help you with
what's the tool called rob are we
allowed to know the name of it yeah so
i this is a strange thing where i do
tutorial videos and i'm doing tutorial
videos for things that aren't quite
released yet so it's like it's in my
head that we have it and it's working
but it's not out just yet but it's going
to be very soon essentially in the web
application
you can type in a keyword and then we
have this tool which turns that keyword
into
how you might ask questions
for that keyword for example i put in a
mortgage as an example and when i was
doing a tutorial and it came with 100
different ways to ask a question about
mortgage like how to remortgage your
house how to get a second mortgage how
to um uh how to get a buy to let
mortgage it was working out all of the
hows where's whys
and any and how-to explanations for that
keyword
but i don't have it yet so which is
really frustrating because i was going
to demonstrate it so it's coming with
that with the absence of that
if i i have put in a search for key the
keyword for epilepsy
and i'm getting these suggestions back
such as epilepsy awareness month what is
epilepsy epilepsy cure epilepsy action
epilepsy treatment so these are all the
general keywords they're going to help
you generate some potential ideas
you solve a tool at the beginning of
this live stream uh where you can put
that idea into a title generator to
bring up some really interesting
clickable questions and intriguing um
titles and then also we have what's
called the thumbnail preview tool
where you can um upload the title and
the thumbnail
and then type out what you want to rank
for in terms of a search term and then
it will show you your video against
other videos that already rank for that
title and thumbnail it like puts you
second in the list so you can say
oh my thumbnail and titles probably
aren't as appealing as the highest
ranked videos so maybe i should retweet
the title or
make
some adjust adjustments of the thumbnail
to make it more clickable so i think
those are the three primary research and
optimization tools i'll be thinking for
uh for for this channel
wow that is so useful rob and that is
one of the reasons why i just love it iq
because there's all these different
tools to help us optimize to help us
learn what we should be doing to help us
make the best videos possible so great
job dr omar on what you're creating and
i can't wait to see what happens in the
future for you all right the next
question comes from a c designs garage
um what else should you be putting in
your description i struggle to know how
much is enough now in i want to just
show this to the audience real quick so
they're knowing what we're talking about
here's our latest video um from think
media the best iphone video settings in
2022
and uh below that
you have this this is your description
and when you're in the back end of your
youtube channel is where you actually
plug in this information so
um what we like to do let me walk you
through just a couple things that we do
here at think media is just our own best
practices and maybe rob can share um
some best practices that they do uh for
theirs as well
we always want to know what the call to
action is so we are always in the first
two to three lines putting in our call
to action to where we want someone to go
next because we're using youtube as our
marketing machine to help us grow our
business and so part of that is we want
to help people go to their next step we
have something for you here is one of
our mottos and so one of the ways you
can do that is by going to whatever the
call to action is now if we are in
partnership with a brand um or there is
a certain tool that we want someone to
go to we will make sure that that is in
the first three lines of text why you
ask because unless you click a little uh
button that moves this down so you can
see all the description all you see at
the beginning is three lines of text and
so we want to make sure that whether
someone knows how to read the full
description or not that they know that
there is a call to action there for them
um next we clarify if the video is
sponsored or not sponsored we're doing
quite a bit of sponsorships now and so
we just want our audience to be aware of
that um and we want to be in full
compliance with youtube
in saying if a video is sponsored or not
we have we love sponsored videos because
we get to share the tools that we love
with our audience that we know that will
be beneficial to you
and then we go down into the show notes
and we just talk about um different uh
um
if we recommended a different video or
if we want you to go
somewhere else and then we do time codes
we have a whole video about how to do
time codes and i'll make sure that our
team drops that in to the description of
this video as well as uh into the
comments of this live stream so you can
learn how to do time codes and why
they're important and then we give our
business shout outs we go down the list
of the different ways that you can
become a part of think media at
different levels because we have
something for you here we always ask a
question in it as well in case someone's
reading through this a lot of people
love to read description boxes to get
more info and then we always say what
this video is about and part of that is
actually to just help
feed as much information to youtube as
we can um so that youtube knows exactly
what this video is about and then we
have our disclaimer that actually takes
you over to our website um to make sure
that we're doing all of our disclaimer
policies in align with youtube so that's
what we do rob for our description box
how about you guys over at vid iq
anything particular you'd add i'm just
curious however how much of that was uh
from the upload defaults in your
description um really great question um
everything but time codes so we uh
like these emojis are all part of it
this is part of it and then uh this line
here says in our default
uh we have like give what the call to
action is yeah
that uploads that yeah puts that in
there it just kind of gives us triggers
show notes one two what is this about
all of this actually stays the same
unless we need to change for a reason
but the default mode is the best hack
rob yeah um we're pretty similar in that
we have a call to action above the fold
if you want to describe it as that um
but our call to action is usually to
watch uh another related video
so we have i've become very intentional
with my calls to action where i will
send somebody
to the same video whether it's the end
screen the pinned comments or in the
description um
we're trying to keep people on youtube
to watch more of our content but i
completely understand why yourselves at
think media and others want people to go
off of platforms and maybe get them into
an emailing list or you know to get them
invested in the channel outside of
youtube
i think what i will
say ultimately is that
whatever concerns you have about the
description i want you to take 95 of
those concerns time and effort and
invest it in a title and a thumbnail
because they are so so important the
description is something that you
probably want to start to worry about
once you've figured out those really
crucial aspects um but i think
everything else you included in there
heather was very similar to us in terms
of
a description of a video in about 150
characters you know
imagine you're promoting your channel
your video in a tweet at the beginning
of a video and then calls to action and
time codes
yeah really really smart and
time codes wasn't even something i was
doing on videos actually was super funny
when time codes first came out rob i was
like timecode everything and then i had
like a five minute video and uh our
editor
messaged me and he's like you want me to
time code your five minute video i'm
like no no sorry you don't need to time
code that that basically is the answer
so even with time codes um just like rob
said that if people won't even click on
your video your description doesn't
actually matter if the video isn't great
your description doesn't actually matter
so really putting the time and energy
into those big pieces which is getting
people to click on your video and
keeping people watching that's what
youtube wants the game of youtube is
those two things getting people to click
and keeping people watching because the
more time people spend on the platform
the more money is generated for youtube
and for the creators on the platform so
um
that is going to wrap up this segment of
our q a and uh rob uh send us out with
um
just some encouragement for those who
are just getting started on youtube this
is the youtube made simple show so why
don't you tell us a little bit of
encouragement for those who are seeing
the channel reviews feeling slightly
overwhelmed by what they need to create
next um what advice would you have for
that new creator
there's a simple answer as to why um i
have a million subscribers
and it's because i've turned up to make
videos for the last
decade
and 2 000
videos
even if you don't have the right idea or
something's not really clicking
with uh your presentation in front of
camera or you just can't figure out how
to make thumbnails if you keep chipping
away
and aiming to improve one percent with
every single video you will get there
you will figure it out and you will get
to your goals
faster than i did and that's all i'm
here to do in terms of educating people
is to
be able to
share the the experience of turning a
passionate hobby into a career but i
want people to get to that goal quicker
than i was able to achieve it and that
you will certainly do that if you
put your faith and trust in not only
vidiq's tools but the education uh that
heather and the think media team have
especially in that masterclass if you've
not joined it definitely uh start your
youtube journey there
so good well thank you so much robin hey
if you didn't know rob and i both work
for youtube channels and if you want to
figure out how rob got hired at vid iq
or how i was able to work here at think
media you can click or tap the screen
right now to watch that video and if you
want to see other videos in this series
of the youtube made simple show where we
are breaking down different channel
reviews and answering your questions you
can click or tap the screen right now
thank you so much